when you asked me how how did i get
started yeah yeah because the whole got
the cheeto thing yeah yeah so uh i was i
was um
i went back to memphis i got out of
college and i used to be friends with
this guy you had to wrestle in college
i'm in high school and he was training
mma and were you a good i don't mean a
rep were you a good wrestler in high
school
uh i just started at sixth street i was
undefeated until regional finals okay
did you but did you play a sport in
college or no wrestle oh you're
wrestling in college yeah i sucked i won
one wrestling match okay yeah i sucked
but you know i liked i was new to it
yeah you liked it and and uh so he took
me to the mma show like on those small
shows and i saw this fighter there i
didn't know who he was and uh he's he
trained or took somebody the guy tapped
out the referee stopped the fight he put
his foot in the guy face and pushed him
off and i said i want to fight that guy
he's a [ __ ] dick and then my friend
started training for a fight three days
notice they said hey you wanna fight
i'm like yeah fight who is they say you
remember that guy you said you wanna
fight they said yeah his opponent pulled
out and i get that it's mike powell
he was he was like undefeated in memphis
he was the biggest the highest bid he
was like purple something like that and
what happened i i ended up beating him
by decision damn
my first fight ever my first fight ever
i beat him by the city and they said oh
you're a fighter now and then then my
friend he moved to uh he he went and
fought in ufc 19 or 20 something like
that and he and he met fabian on iha
and then they became friends and then he
he flew out to california with his wife
and stuff and started training six
months later he he sent for me i quit my
job i left my i love my family everybody
and it was a pretty fast for you once
you got to california
i can't remember i'm bad with time but i
was out here i was out here for a while
and fabiano he didn't he didn't he
didn't charge me i was broke as [ __ ] i
couldn't i couldn't afford rent i just
left everything i took me a while to
fight two about six months to find that
damn bouncing job down maybe like forty
five dollars a [ __ ] night and and so
far he didn't charge me so he threw this
show that's why i met uh uh joe daddy
stevenson
he beat my friend he beat the [ __ ] out
of my friend on that show and i fought
for free and he was trying to pay on
that now man you don't charge me i'll
fight for freedom so that was my that
was my uh second fight my second amateur
fight and then um
then after that i think i fought marvin
eastman and king the cage and then
that's what we're not racist yeah for
some reason i remember so many wait you
fought marvin twice i fought mama twice
yeah i didn't know that i didn't know he
beat the [ __ ] out of me the first fight
oh he did it was that a lot of memories
but that was your first fight that was
your first fight in ufc right when you
first got the use yeah yeah that's that
was my deal see the ufc they brought w
was it wfa they brought wfa for my
contract because remember
remember chuck was coming back avenging
all his losses yeah the last guy you
knocked me out with that left hook right
there
yeah
i was the last i was the last guy you
did you and trucker cool now man
manchego is cool i'm gonna tell y'all
how chuck chuck messed up
he mixed up uh that that that that that
was a right hook that was all his fault
because oh oh he missing it
oh sure you're strong
he's done he's done yeah chuck chuck
liddell when we found in japan chuckled
there gave me the hardest body shot i
ever
received in my life right and when he
hit me in the body i made a noise and he
remembered it i meant no he hit me
and i went for the takedown and then the
bill rang right so when we fought when
we fought in in ufc
he was trying to set me up for that body
shot same body shot and that's what
that's what that's what allows him to
fight oh damn he was trying to go for
that body shot oh that's it and then you
know and and and i i i counted the
butter shot and hooked and and and i
came you guys worked on that in camp yep
who no no but but that's my style when
people go for the body i have i have
like these reflections start working
with a boxing coach i think for that
camp because i remember you gave him a
shout out because i remember yeah you
know i remember you caught him and you
were like and you said you gave him a
shout out and said we worked on like for
my boxing like he yeah i think that was
vanilla when i knocked that ventilate
for the first time i worked with
i brought a
boxing coach from england okay but but
but but i did have a boxing uh coach for
the um for the chuckle dead fire how
good did that feel because you did go to
the van related fight how good did that
feel get that win that was my favorite
one that was your favorite favorite stop
because you didn't go to what's it what
yeah i went over there
yeah corner corner waved it off that
that's smart save you yeah that was that
was the fight that i was waiting because
after you got that one back i was like
god he's got to be feeling so good about
that because right now because i always
knew i could beat ventilate i always
knew that i could beat him but i just
wasn't stuck but i just wasn't prepared
like when i first i was training with i
was sparring with jiu jitsu guys
i didn't i didn't have like a um a team
of people to spar and bang with so i was
sparring with just two guys who didn't
want to be in the ring with me they
didn't want to be in the cage i wouldn't
want me in the ring with you
just being honest
it was it was it was hard it was hard to
prepare for for vanilla and shogun and
ninja you know it's hard because those
guys
a lot of boxers like like just strictly
boxers or not a whole lot yeah